replicants are like any other machine
they're either a benefit or a hazard if
they're a benefit it's not my problem
[Music]
not at your job once that was good
things were simpler then
[Music]
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so Blade Runner
trailer let's break it down if you
didn't know this is a sequel it's not a
reboot there gonna be a couple other big
trailers this holiday season so make
sure you enable alerts so that you don't
miss anything but what's going on here
is that this is a sequel to the original
Blade Runner movie so even if you don't
remember the plot of the first Blade
Runner movie or anything like the big
mysteries behind it you kind of get the
sense from here it's a very Star Wars
The Force awakens style plot teaser
where they say 30 years after the first
film Ryan Gosling's character named K
with the LA Police Department finds a
secret they could throw what's left of
society into chaos in what he finds out
like the big mystery leads him to seek
out Deckard who's been missing for the
past 30 years so you get the idea like
Star Wars The Force awakens Luke has
been missing for 30 years there's this
big new secret that's uncovered they
have to go find him
so this new Blade Runner movie is sort
of passing the torch in the way star
wars is to Ryan Gosling who's kind of
the new Deckard style character but will
address some of the mysteries too
because there's still some of the
lingering mysteries of the first film
and they said that they're not going to
answer whether or not Deckard is a
replicant but Ridley Scott has actually
speculated on that so I'll include some
of that in this video but you see how
they begin the trailer with dialogue
that's directly copied from the first
film that Deckard monologue is right out
of the first film if they cause problems
then it's my job to take them down
then you see Ryan Gosling's characters
seek out Deckard in this
post-apocalyptic wasteland it looks like
society is crumbling even though you see
him walking through a city earlier in
the trailer but he plays the piano it's
the same tune from the first movie
that's kind of meant to end the film
making you wonder whether or not Deckard
was really a replicant and that Harrison
Ford steps out the old man so you're
like wait a minute
so most of my thoughts from this trailer
are like you know wait a minute does
that mean that replicants can age the
real revelation of the movie is
obviously tied to the idea of humanity
who's a replicant who's a real person
what is a real person do Androids Dream
of Electric Sheep all of the big twists
from the first film but approach in a
slightly different way trying to
recontextualize it like Ryan Gosling's
character tries to me
it sound like things are so much more
complicated now that maybe technology
has advanced so much that you can no
longer distinguish between human and
replicant like at the beginning of the
original movie the replicant Leon
glitches out and attacks the person
giving it this voight-komp test that's
what they called it in the movie it was
just a test designed to distinguish
replicants based on their emotional
responses to questions maybe what Ryan
Gosling's character is implying is that
they can now pass that test it's no
longer effective they're just questions
Leon in answer to your query they're
written down for me it's a test designed
to provoke an emotional response shall
we continue describe in single words
only the good things that come into your
mind about your mother mother because
the only other like super big twist that
I could think of would be like a
Battlestar Cylon situation where this
has all happened before like society
crumbled and matrix-style they're just
in a different iteration of the same
loop over and over where humanity rises
up creates replicants replicants kill
off humans then they themselves
transcend humanity in the whole cycle
starts again or it's a much simpler
twist and everyone has been a replicant
this whole time so you guys can let me
know what you think you know based on
some of the twists and the questions set
up in the first film you know what is a
replicant Do Androids Dream of Electric
Sheep are they capable of being more
human than human maybe the person that
you thought was a human this whole time
has really been a replicant and like I
said it's a little frustrating but the
director did say that they try to avoid
addressing directly whether or not
Deckard is a replicant so in the context
of the original film replicants are only
supposed to live for about four years
like that's their cycle then they get
decommissioned so you don't really know
if a replicant can age so I can see how
it was easy for them to step around that
issue because you could still be a
replicant and be old like they have
tissue so the tissue would
age if you haven't seen the original
film in a while the reason people think
that Deckard was a replicant is because
he keeps having dreams of this unicorn
then gaff at the end of the film who
makes these origami figures edward james
olmos so you know be talking about
Battlestar Cylon twists Edward James
Olmos makes an origami unicorn and sets
it on the piano just like the piano that
Ryan Gosling is playing in this so it
just meant to imply the Deckard was a
replicant this whole time
[Music]
during an interview in 2000 redly Scott
seemingly confirmed that he thought
Deckard was a replicant but the problem
is is that he didn't write the film in
the people that have wrote the film and
like everyone else has said that this
isn't canon because he's not the writer
in the actual writer of the film would
be the one to confirm or disconfirm the
theory which they have not done so you
could actually make the argument Deckard
was a replicant Deckard is not a
replicant either way but I have a
feeling that just like Star Wars The
Force awakens
Harrison Ford probably won't be involved
with this franchise if he continues
forward so do not be surprised if he
dies during the film after a very long
monologue about all the sights that he
is seen just Rutger Hauer style one of
the best monologues in sci-fi film
history
[Music]
attack ships on fire off the shoulder of
a lion
I watched c-beams glitter in the dark
near the Tannhauser game
all does
moments will be lost in time like tears
but overall the film looks fantastic
just based on the trailer the set design
the original film if you haven't watched
in a while go back and re-watch it again
it is one of the most iconic sci-fi
films from the 80s it has some of the
most amazing architecture you've ever
seen in a film so what's gonna happen
next is I have some Rick and Morty
season 3 footage I'll post that there
may be some new Justice League posting
tomorrow if there isn't that I have some
flash season 3 that I'll post while you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for all my Star Wars rogue one
Easter eggs and you can click here for
the Justice League teaser that just
dropped thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]